man big month couple nominations
birthday coming up must feel good right
now this is a beautiful time of year for
me because it is my birthday but because
and maybe because it was my it's my
birthday but the holiday seasons always
special for me to me obviously as
special with with fences coming out
Christmas Day yeah you know but the
nominations what is it like to
constantly have your work I mean
acknowledged by your peers and getting
that Golden Globe nomination as well it
feels great
I mean you you you busting you behind
you trying your best so for when when
people say that then you know yeah you
know we all want to be tough guys are
they don't mean nothing to me but yeah
it does yeah it does it was especially
satisfying for me to get the what are
they I don't know the title of best
ensemble whatever yes AG award yeah
because I've had a lot of success what's
important for me in life is to see
others do well especially as it relates
to this film well I ain't got to worry
about it others are doing well survival
is killing yeah Stephen Henderson is
holding down the bottom subtle Micheal T
Williams is killing so I'm happy that
the actors recognize what the actors are
doing in fences tell my Screen Actors
Guild I'm happy that the Golden Globes
and whichever Awards it is they're
they're saying we appreciate the
brilliance of August Wilson and the
brilliance of the of the actors and for
me as the director that's that that's
satisfying enough and what age you know
you reach this age as it as a kid
sometimes where you start to think that
maybe you could take your dad mm-hmm and
what age was that for you you start
looking at and thinking
no I didn't have that you know I wasn't
with him in long enough for that I was
out of house or he was at it out so I
was out of his house at 14 I had it with
my son I had that basketball game you
know it got physical you know that
happens we did it in and he got game it
happens yeah it happens yeah you know
this movie comes out I know last year
there was a lot that you spoke on 60
minutes about it there's a lot of
controversy on award season being very
white and you know there's a lot of
ethnic films that have been acknowledged
this year and and you know in TV series
that make knowledge that are
predominantly ethnic during this award
season thus far more so than ever before
or maybe not more so than ever before
but there seems to be a trend that's
increasing well and you know one of the
conversations I had with a couple my
friends is does it change that how
substantial or what it means having
happened the year after there was that
kind of quote-unquote kind of
conversation and protests of sorts well
we were making this the first of all
fences has won every award it could win
yeah thirty years ago and seven years
ago when we did it so it was already all
right yeah we were already planning to
make it and I decided to make it before
the Oscars last year so that didn't have
anything to do with us I assume and I
don't know but you know things and Barry
Jenkins yeah Barry Jenkins has made his
film I'm seen yet made his film and
stuck to it and fought for his story he
told his story what I tell young people
of any color tell your story don't be
don't have your life dictated by outside
circumstances keep working on your story
and when you get your chance when I
looked up Barry up he had done about 25
or 30 shorts so he kept flooding he can
plug and he kept plugging you know you
gotta fight this this ain't no easy
business and it's harder when you think
you have someone else to blame
now if whatever's happening this year is
because of what didn't happen last year
okay but I can tell you this August
Wilson earned
he won the Pulitzer Prize and multiple
Tony Awards and when we did it again
he won multiple 20 Awards again so here
we are we'll see what happened cool Regt